[Music]
first of all I like to say that you're
my favorite person ever in the world but
my question is do you think we can build
our own modern-day Frankenstein don't
expel any other body parts and somehow
reanimating it do you think that's
possible because you seem like a person
to ask this anyway thank you so much I
hope you see how big think Lauren
reanimating people from different body
parts
probably not but something even more
amazing is about to happen in biology
and genetics I have a one Clair point of
clarification dr. Frankenstein created
what came to be called Frankenstein's
monster the monster himself was not
really called Frankenstein just a little
a little science fiction point of
interest there so what will probably
happen in your lifetime just judging how
old you appear on big things is people
will be able people like you will be
able to regenerate parts of your body
using your own cells that technologists
in medicine and genetics are finding
ways to get your own body to create more
cells that it wouldn't that didn't use
to be able to create like if you need a
new pancreas you'll be able to grow your
own pancreas and I don't know about
complex mechanical systems like hands
and fingers but it doesn't seem beyond
the technology that's being developed
right now because in my lifetime people
came to appreciate the significance of
stem cells these are cells that are have
plenty of potential they can be anything
when you're a blastocyst before you
become take on the form of a human or
what have you so the acronym is CRISPR
and the I know the P there is palindrome
palindromic
which is the same at both ends the same
backwards and forwards and so people are
being are finding ways geneticists are
finding ways to get cells to do whatever
they want whatever they want them to do
and it's presumed that instead of making
a monster akin to dr. Frankenstein's
fictional creature by assembling pieces
of from disparate other humans instead
you'd get each person's own cells to
create regenerate body parts or or maybe
in in the in the womb create
extraordinary people that was
extraordinarily smart with extraordinary
skills at dunking basketballs or what
have you but the idea of taking your
consciousness and putting it in another
device or another system or another
biological another person another
biological system if something's been
around for a long time science fiction
has got it for a long time and I'm
always charmed by the singularity when
brains when computers are going to be as
complex and sophisticated as a human
brain and that this this moment in
history is called a singularity and then
you'll just download all of your
memories and all of your experiences
into this electronic presumed electronic
storage system and then you would live
as long as you're plugged in as long as
you have electricity what have you it
just seems way more complicated than
that and not something I would ever
count on and I don't think you can
really be a whole person in the way you
seem to be here on camera without your
senses without your eyes ears nose and
so on feeling the world around you so
called your so-called central nervous
system which is part of your brain I
don't think it's that simple to put a
brain in another body and carry on or
put your consciousness and electrical
receptacle and carry on but you may be
living
at a time when extraordinary things will
be done with your own cells that will
far surpass anything that dr.
Frankenstein in the story was able to do
it's exciting carry on
[Music]